Sure. So look, you know, we're,
we're living through probably the biggest medical scandal today is that there's
a sudden spike and these teenage girls out of nowhere, medically transitioning,
all of a sudden they want hormones and surgeries and they're easily obtaining
them. And, um,
I wrote a book about it and because two Twitter users decided the
book was transphobic. Um,
they told that they called it that to target target removed it.
[inaudible].
Dave Rubin.
And this is the Rubin report joining me today for a long overdue interview is
author of the new book, irreversible damage, the transgender craze,
seducing our daughters, Abigail Shrier, welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks so much for having me on.
So the book came out in June and kind of caught fire in June,
and then I was going to have you on in August. And I went off the grid and then,
you know, there was election stuff, so I didn't have Yon.
And then a couple of weeks ago,
all hell broke loose because target tweeted that they were going to no
longer carry the book.
So let's just start with the controversy because actually the reason I'm having
you on right now is that after the controversy, uh,
the book absolutely sold out everywhere and we had to hold this interview so
that the book would be stocked again. So a lot's going on.
So let's just start with the controversy first,
because what you write about here and the transgender craze is really
like the hot topic of the day and the thing that seems to get the most people in
hot water. So what happened with target? Let's start there.
Sure. So look, you know, we're,
we're living through probably the biggest medical scandal today is that there's
a sudden spike and these teenage girls out of nowhere, medically transitioning,
all of a sudden they want hormones and surgeries and they're easily obtaining
them. And, um,
I wrote a book about it and because two Twitter users decided the
book was transphobic. Um, they told that they called it that to target, target,
removed it. And people were very upset. You know,
the book has a lot of grassroots support.
A lot of parents feel like it really explained the story of what happened to
them when they're teenagers suddenly out of the blue,
decided with their friends that they were transgender. And, um,
they were really upset and a lot of people wrote to target and target, you know,
reinstated it. It was you, uh, you know,
one of the few victories I think against cancel culture.
Yeah. You,
must've been pretty enthused to see the amount of support that you got because
yeah,
you get the usual Twitter haters and the anonymous accounts and all that stuff,
you know, pushing target to a decision like this. But,
but pretty much everybody that still stands on the side of free speech.
I guess we don't have that many people anymore,
but pretty much everyone that was around supported you to get this thing back.
And it actually did work.
Yeah. I was very gratified. Look, you know,
there are literally hundreds of books out there promoting
unskeptical early, the immediate medical transition of teenagers.
If you want to read that book, there are hundreds you could read. And,
and you know what I, you know,
I certainly would never call for any of them to be banned because I don't want
to live in that kind of world. But you know,
there is exactly one book that did a deep dive into this phenomenon of teenage
girls suddenly transitioning. And it's my book and for the activists,
even one book is too many.
Yeah. Okay. So let's start with the most important converse question.
Let's just get it out there, right from the top. Abigail, are you a transphobia?
Do you have an irrational fear of trans people?
And is that why you wrote this book?
No, I wrote the book, first of all,
because a reader wrote to me and she told me her daughter had gone through this
phenomenon. And when she, um, you know,
she said her daughter had always been a girly girl, never had gender dysphoria.
This is, um, severe discomfort in one's biological sex.
But when she got to high school,
she had a lot of mental health issues and she went off to college and with a
group of girlfriends, they all decided they were transgender.
And she started a course of testosterone.
And I tried to find another investigative journalist who would take it up
because I had, you know,
I wasn't an investigative journalist and I couldn't find one.
So after four months I finally got back in touch with her and I said, all right,
I'll do it. I mean, that's, that's the world we're living in. And,
and let me just say that a lot of transgender adults and I interviewed a lot for
my book support the book. I mean, the book does not,
I'm not against medical transition.
It just urges caution when it comes to these teenage girls.
So just to be absolutely clear, and I know my audience totally understands it,
but so you don't have a problem with adults that transition that make
the choice in their lives to transition?
No, I mean, not only am I not against it,
I've interviewed a lot of transgender adults. I believe it has helped, um,
trans it can help. Um, I know them,
like I talked to them and I'll tell you something else.
I'm not even against all medical transition for teenagers.
The only thing I sh I show in the blog is that the current medical regime
has no medical judgment in place.
It's totally based on the judgment of teenagers.
And the doctors are told to affirm, affirm, affirm,
meaning they have to agree with the teenager.
Self-diagnosis so there's no checks in place. So the regime,
the current medical regime is really not safe for teenage girls.
Yeah. So I was trying to think how I wanted to conduct this interview because,
you know, this is one of the topics that we've touched on a bunch here.
Not because I particularly care about these issues as much as
when it's become such a hot button issue, then it sort of gets to my plate.
But I thought I read the book and I thought that the way that you laid it out,
uh, just even in the chapters,
the way you separated certain things was really good. So if you don't mind,
we'll just go through chapter by chapter and discuss each one.
So the introduction is about the contagion and that's sort of what you're
hitting on about what happened with, uh, with your friend's daughter at college.
Can you, can you describe that?
Sure. So, um,
it's based on the research of Lisa as we'll talk about in the next chapter, but,
um,
the public health researcher who looked into why there was a sudden huge spike
in teenage girls who claimed to have gender dysphoria,
and this is not the population that traditionally had it, it was always males.
And it usually began in early childhood. And all of a sudden across the West,
including America,
we have this sudden spike of teenage girls deciding they're transgender often
with their friends and often after the encouragement of social media
influencers.
Right? So you talk about this a little bit later in the book.
So I'm jumping ahead a bit,
but you tell a story of a girl who in essence in high school came out as
transgender. There,
there weren't a lot of issues that she was bringing up before that,
but then suddenly she's getting more likes on tumbler.
She's now part of an oppressed minority at school and in different groups.
And that, that allure basically,
and I know I'm getting a little ahead of ourselves here, but,
but that allure in a weird way is what's fueling so much of this.
That's right? So it's young teenage girls. These are often white,
middle or upper middle class girls. They're very precocious. Um,
but they are high anxiety and high depression girls.
They have a lot of mental health issues. And for the first time,
the moment they get to high school and or middle school and decide they're
transgender, you know,
it's the first time they get so much encouragement and love,
especially online and sometimes from adults and,
and some of these adults are not, you know, are, are not up to very much good.
Um,
but they get the showering of love and praise and they don't want to walk away
from that.
So chapter one, which is about the girls that you're describing right there,
you know, we've talked a lot about it. And I think, you know,
I was on tour with Jordan Peterson for a year and a half and he focused more.
So I would say on young men, but it was a message that obviously traversed,
it didn't matter what gender you really were,
but is there something specific going on with young girls that we're
not aware of?
Like there does seem to be an a masculization of young boys that we see,
but what do you think is happening with young girls?
Right.
So teenage girls specifically fall for almost every one of these so-called as
stereos. And the reason they do is they tend to take on their friend's pain.
If a young man is depressed, very often, his friend will say, okay,
let's go play basketball or, or suggest doing something. But he won't say,
what are you feeling? Tell me about your pain.
And he won't start to take it on himself.
He won't agree with his friend about how terrible life is just to make his
friend feel better. But we know,
and I interviewed a lot of psychologists about this young women tend to not only
take on their friend's pain,
they're willing to distort reality in order to make their friend feel better.
Um, and, and so that's why they tend to, you know, all of these, you know, um,
anorexia is spread this way. They tend to, you know, take on whatever their,
their friend's reality is. Even if it's, Oh, I'm too fat. I'm whatever they,
they think will make their friend feel better. They'll take that on.
If you're looking for more honest and conversations about.
Women's issues, instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our women's issues playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.